I provoked strong opinions are you ready
there's so much to talk about okay I
didn't grow up thinking about going into
politics but much to my surprise was
elected president the public ends I got
into law school I thought I'm gonna try
to make a difference in people's lives I
took a class and I saw Hillary sitting
there and he was watching me and she
closed the wall group they said if
you're gonna keep looking at me and I'm
going to keep looking back we ought to
know each other's names I'm Hillary
Rodham who are you she was different
than anybody I ever met I said I really
want to marry you but he shouldn't marry
me there is a set of expectations out of
first lady I violated them from the very
beginning she brought to the forefront
women's roles in society this is radical
feminism he decided to ask Hillary to
become Secretary of State surprised
people Hillary's polarizing human rights
are women's rights and women's rights
are human rights people would run up
clutching copies of that speech reciting
that line from it email emails bang it
played into all of the suspicions she's
so sketching cold calculating she could
actually be crazy there is this sense
that she knows that she is an ethical
moral person and that can blind anyone
you know you get scarred up a little bit
it wasn't like I thought how can I think
about the most stupid thing I could
possibly do and do it I didn't want
anything to do with him
Chelsea put herself between us and held
both our hands as long as she has been
in a public life there have been these
ups and downs you know be our champion
go away you want to make a difference
you want to have an impact well then you
got to get in the arena
[Music]
you